Current government regulations require
about $98 billion to be
on the books of our banks.
We have a little more than that.
We have $2.4 trillion in excess of our reserves.
I think that's a lot of money.
You could do a lot of work with that money,
if that money got invested into businesses.
What does that mean in terms of scale?
It's about two-thirds of the entire federal budget.
That is a lot of money just sitting there just like it
did in the Great Depression.
But where do banks have their money? Maybe
their money is already tied up in risky
business ventures. They don't want anymore.
Is that the case?  No, that's also not the case.
This is a graph of business loans and consumer loans.
I checked this 16 different ways.
I couldn't believe it when I saw this.
That right now consumer debt is around $3.5 trillion.
And this is business loans, this is like negligible.
It's a few hundred billion dollars.
97% less. I don't know about you,
but this is not how capitalism is supposed to work.
Those are supposed to be flip-flopped.
That's how economies grow.
They don't grow through consumer debt.
But if you're curious about how this happened,
there is a book, that I wrote, called "Borrow",
that I can tell you about how that happened.
But basically the idea is that it became much easier
to securitize all this consumer debt,
to bundle it up and sell it on capital markets,
than it is for business debt.
In fact it's not possible really to do that now.
In fact our largest government agency
that's supposed to be in charge of doing this
doing what we imagine--what the
Reconstruction Finance Corporation did in the 01930s
the Small Business Administration
does hardly any of it.
So $15 billion--this is like a drop in the bucket
compared to either the size of banks
or even the entire market for small business loans
if you include real estate. Why is this?
It's because we've had government
policies in the 1960s and 70s
that made it possible to securitize consumer debt.
To make it easier for banks and lenders and investors
to put money into your credit cards
than into your small business.
Than into even your large business.
And this is from a report from the Federal Reserve.
A report to Congress. Why it's not possible to do this.
Now I think if it's possible to hide Greek debt
by Goldman Sachs. If it's possible for all those
wizards of Wall Street to do all the magic
they do every day, we can probably do
for small business debt what we did for
for houses in Texas in the 01930s (before they
had computers or... you know anything really).
They're just primitive, cavemen...
That's point one.
Point two: it would not fix the new leading sector.
How do we find this new leading sector?
For instance we're all excited about self-driving cars...
Who's excited about self-driving cars?
I'm excited about self-driving cars.
I hate driving. I like sleeping and reading.
Now this will create a lot of demand
I'm very excited, this is a good thing.
It will create a lot of demand though.
Not just for the cars, the replacement of all our cars,
but also the rebuilding of our cities. The rebuilding
of our entire built environment around these cars.
A lot of connections. A lot of growth.
This is the kind of thing that
could be part of a new leading sector.
It is the right direction.
Now the other thing I want to talk about with that is...
that sounded crazy... how many years ago?
Two? 3 years ago? If I was here five years ago,
and I was like: "Hey, I'm making a self-driving car"
You'd be like "Yeah, good luck with your rocket boots!"
And yet it's possible. It's a failure of imagination.
In fact we see this all the time in our society.
A failure of imagination.
Which stems from a basic failure of science.
Which I'm going to come back to.
We live in an era that is not disruptive
but incrementalist. Bear with me.
Most of the science we build our technology on
the basic scientific principles (electricity,
quantum mechanics) have resulted in products
that have been refined since the 1960s
Since the 1950s even in a lot of ways.
Incrementalist. Note, this room
basically would look the same 50 years ago.
Whereas 50 years before that none of it would exist.
We think we live in a time of technological change,
but it's actually relatively slow.
Because we have cut off imagination
and have cut off innovative science.
Now a good test of what a new leading sector would be:
does it sound as crazy as a self-driving car?
What are some of the kinds of crazy things
you could imagine in the future? I named rocket boots.
Those sounds totally insane.
I want to point out one thing that also...
10 years ago when I was talking about this with my wife
and we were in grad school,
I was like self-driving cars
and space elevators. Space elevators, right?
Those sound crazy, right? Yeah! A big strip
of material into space with an elevator attached?
That's ludicrous. But imagine what it would be like.
It's the right order of thinking.
Something totally, totally new.
A platform for other industries.
Radical new materials science.
And most importantly millions and millions of jobs.
As a platform for new possibilities
And again I am NOT an industrialist.
I am NOT a scientist even.
So I have no stake in this.
If this happens I will not make any money.
I would not even be allowed in space.
Because my wife thinks I'm going to die there.